okay so what's about to happen is we're
gonna shoot I'm gonna show you how
Supergirl flies this is me here on the
set of Supergirl you're that on the set
actual production and that I found this
fascinating I'm doing this [ __ ] since I
was a pup right
making flicks but I'll make [ __ ] like
this so this is fascinating to me today
on the last day on the show which has
gone very well Eric how well did it go
it went fantastic character writer Eric
still here talking fine you know [ __ ]
that was my line don't take my line you
will believe a girl comply we're gonna
show you how this all your the bells the
production bells will show you how
fascinated this [ __ ] is you want to see
what it takes to make Supergirl fly it
takes a village watch this I'm gonna go
this way no that's probably that look
[ __ ] up
look at this gigantic ass green screen
look at all these people look at every
look at all this equipment my burgers
walking around with headpieces and [ __ ]
like that just to end there she goes
look at her a lot
now here that's happening right there
yes look at that man is Melissa
everybody give it up for Melissa okay so
we're gonna show you the monitor this is
what it looks like right here on the
monitor that's a shooting on green
screen
cutting time give it up for Melissa yeah
[Applause]
in that crazy how they have to go
through that much effort just to make
her fly that many people are involved
and putting one person in there and
stuff and you watch it on the show and
you're like oh you take it for granted
you take for granted then she flies but
look look at the look at the look at how
much money just batshit crazy man this
like I said is the final day we've got
some other stuff to shoot but it's all
green screen for the moment and she's
going up on one more flight so we'll
you'll get to see it again
fascinating right rich play some music
for us it's background music by fire
rich rich is going to DJ it up for us so
we got something to listen to it's been
a fantastic week here telomeric so
writer eric writer eric guy who writes
super girl flies and it takes me 10
seconds and then this happens
uh don't you feel those you feel
terrible like look it's so guilty i just
write these things and we were just
talking about him in the room and we
don't really think about nerds gonna
tell characters good [ __ ] yell
delicious to be pushed
they [ __ ] just cuz production is
difficult and hard there we go this it's
about to happen again
alright you're gonna watch your fly
again
[Music]
triangle I can get over that way
Google is good
that's the Supergirl gummy back to the
day
[Music]
[Music]
that's Simon Simon is in charge of
stunts member man who puts her to law
I know it's James the DP but it's just
like a little coke he took you gon make
you famous I'm Simon's directing the
episode everyone give it up as I had one
question just to bring closer into the
Digi double shot this monkeys the
effects when when when she puts her
hands up are we able to just do a little
bit of this if we do that [ __ ] no we can
do we can do a lot of it but we do it as
another she would be pushing and fast
for one where you do the explosion
probably a good idea to that can we just
do exactly the acceptable question
classes we can put it and then you can
react naturally if you want to be aware
and you can even go arms up and go right
yeah that would help to cut it do you
notice that I have absolutely nothing to
do with any of this I'm sitting here
holding the phone or just watching it
happen venomous has a feel to go up in
the air [ __ ] no hi it looked amazing
though what does it feel like when you
go up and then just come down like
you're floating except you're wearing
okay
a very painful day friend that's right
she's gotta wear a harness right she's
wearing a harness in order to put her up
there
goes over her whole body under the suit
and then hooks in man makes it tight so
when she goes up the but uh she's so
sweet about it incredibly gracious and
graceful why she's about to happen again
and see over there I'm pointing at the
screen you can't even see me pointing
like a dummy
that's Atlin she's this stunt double
Supergirl and there's the other
Supergirl and then like I said there's
the was the dummy Supergirl that just
kind of stands in production son
Oh
[Music]
oh come on that was awesome give it up
man one more you perfectionist oh god
how awesome is that we got to see her
fly that nuts like when I was a kid I
saw that Superman movie and the tagline
was you believe man could fly
and had no idea that years later I'd be
somewhere where I watched people do it
and they'd say you're in charge but not
really rich I know you see this [ __ ] all
the time it's pretty awesome right like
it never gets old man never gets old one
iota it's gonna go again tell him what
are we doing never again won't one more
take man no more there's stunts stunts
Atlin right there that first second
really it's her she's over there but
stun Allen is like aan appointment she
looks exactly like her and she used to
be a Cirque du Soleil she just told us
to everybody has more interesting job
than me and Eric did you get the guy
that steers the green-screen means yes
of course I shot the human condom that
was amazing all right they're going up
again we'll watch
[Music]
all that looks your manners give it up
for ladies and gentlemen yes I don't
direct a lot of people direct and I just
make people applaud that's my job on
this set um so there it is man we show
you how Supergirl fly how amazing is
that
Thanks all these people look at all
these people it takes a village all
these it takes all of these Superfriends
if you will to make Supergirl fly thanks
for hanging out man we're gonna go back
to work going back to work see you guys
later thanks for thanks for checking in
on Supergirl
don't forget most importantly I'm in
Canada I already sent my vote in a week
and a half ago two weeks ago
early voting cuz I knew I was gonna be
up here shooting on election day don't
forget to vote I'm telling you to vote
for it but don't forget to vote truth
justice the American Way and all that
stuff if you're in America go vote if
you're not in America don't I don't
support voter fraud anyway there it is
enjoy
you
[Music]